all right these are my favorite clips
today this is so funny uh today on the
bonus show
when i'm joined by producer pat we will
talk about how
suddenly rudy giuliani's son andrew
giuliani
is running for governor of new york and
he appeared on fox news last night and
gave a completely bizarre
and farcical interview but eric trump
didn't want andrew giuliani to outdo him
apparently
so i can't actually tell who gave the
dumbest appearance last night on fox
news let's take a quick listen we're
going to start with eric trump donald
trump's
son not the smartest one i don't think
and
eric trump claims that random people are
coming up to him on the street
crying in tears over
how much they want donald trump back as
president take a look at this
um you know more people i mean i i can
tell you more people have come up to me
on the street in the last week and given
me hugs saying
we miss him so much i mean literally
sometimes sean with tears in their eyes
we
miss the man so much no matter what what
you say about him he loves this country
and he's willing to fight for this
does anybody believe this like i do
believe
that tears have been shed
related to trump as president but i
don't think that they're
they're tears of joy uh then eric trump
claims
that this white house doesn't travel
and that that's really bad but listen to
the
complete inconsistency of what he even
tries to assert here
there's no fight coming out of the white
house there's no one there
they don't travel they don't go down to
the border they don't go overseas they
don't
i mean there's no charisma there's no
there's no anything
did you guys catch that he says this
white house is bad because it doesn't
trap
it doesn't travel and this white house
is bad because there's no one at the
white house
well hold on a second if they're not at
the white house and they're not
traveling like where are they where is
joe biden is it that's
is there is the president just missing
he's he can't be found anywhere he's not
doing any trial
is he at camp david the entire time just
vapid
pointless talking points not even really
a criticism so that's eric trump
that's already really bad but then
in comes andrew giuliani he is running
for governor
of new york state this is rudy
giuliani's son
he's 35 years old he went on tv last
night and declared
anything that will bring money to new
york
he will do period full stop end of story
take a listen well look let's start off
with sports gambling i know much how
much time we have
anything that's going to bring revenue
into new york i am pro
that a lot of people that i know go to
new jersey in order to actually go
and gamble you really feel
like the republican party has no farm
team right now
it's q anon type people like marjorie
taylor green
lauren beaubert and others they may be
the future of the republican party but
it's a really scary future if that's the
future
you then have your trump brown-nosers
who aren't they're not even really young
but they might potentially aspire to
higher office people like kevin mccarthy
or tom cotton josh hawley these types of
people
and then there's the children of
well-known republicans
andrew giuliani the son of rudy giuliani
donald trump jr
eric trump ivanka trump the children of
donald trump
it's not looking great for the country
and many of them may win like i'm not
saying
this looks bad for the republican party
in the sense that they won't ever win
again
trump won so there's a very real risk
that these clowns could win
it's just not looking good for the
country the fact that uh uh
these are people who are uh not
immediately and obviously disqualified
from any role in public office or in
government now um
andrew giuliani seems to have sort of a
savior complex
here he was on hannity last night saying
he will
save the state of new york you just wait
you wait until 2023 and then we're going
to have a nice big party up in albany
and we're going to see
you're going to be at empire state so i
don't know which appearance was more
hair brained
uh eric trump's or andrew giuliani's now
here's a couple of bonus
andrew giuliani clips by the way here he
is yesterday
getting ready to make his announcement
and he seemed confused about whether the
statue he was looking at
was the statue of liberty or some other
statue i mean it's i i don't know take a
look at this
okay let me know whenever you're ready
which one is that is that miss manhattan
or is that lady lift that's lady liberty
over there so
everybody ready yeah so that's that's
something
and then lastly really funny andrew
giuliani said at his announcement
that he will use his dad rudy giuliani
as an
asset i mean you you can't write this
stuff rudy giuliani seems to have been
used as
an asset by so many people in countries
at this point
and andrew giuliani apparently with no
sense of satire or parody whatsoever and
certainly no comic timing that's for
sure
saying he will use rudy as an asset take
a look when you've got the greatest
prosecutor in the history of the
southern district and you've got the
greatest mayor not this
not just in the history of new york but
in the history of america
you're foolish if you don't use him as
an asset so we are in
for a real party here
with andrew giuliani running for
governor these families you know the
trumps the giuliani's
they're in a sense the gifts that keep
on giving
but it is a major indictment of american
society and culture that people like
this can actually attain
power and then that their kids are seen
as at least
possibly legitimate inheritors it heirs
inheritors heirs to that power is
inheritors a word i don't know
certainly ayers is uh heirs to that
power
it is an indictment of the united states
of america and the world sees it they
laugh we've said it before
um truly truly horrible stuff one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman